(electronic music)
- I'm Bobby Bottleservice,
aka Bobby Bottleservice.
Would you date me?
'Cause I think I love you.
Excuse me, no offense, but are
you someone who's very much
in so much as interested
in becoming married?
I think of myself as like a
very cool, very white Jay Z.
(Bleep) chill out.
(laughing)
First and first mostly
for me, it's about family.
Yo, we're having
a great time here
at the Bobby
Bottleservice, full-service
wedding service commercial.
I'm going to put together
the most amazing wedding
you'd ever imagine in your life,
which is how I imagine
my marriage to be.
You're the only woman I've
ever loved, my mother.
Love you too Ma.
- [Ma] It's almost cold.
- I'll come down.
I would never let a
meal go cold on you.
(electronic music)